this is really funny video of Donald
Trump
stepping in it again but this time it's
much more innocuous it's not a crisis
it's just funny ignorant and lack of
context but it actually relates to a
really serious issue related to one of
the most important issues we deal with
as a human species right now and that is
climate change and pollution and what
we're doing to our countries so let's
start with the clip and then talking
about it will be even more illuminating
after we watch make sure if you're
watching on YouTube that you've hit the
subscribe button to our Channel right
now Trump was asked about the plastic
straw controversy and here's what he had
to say I do think we have bigger
problems than plastic straws you know
it's interesting about plastic straws so
you have a little straw but what about
the plates the wrappers and everything
else at a much bigger and they're made
of the same material so the straws are
interesting everybody focuses on the
straws there's a lot of other things to
focus in but it's an interesting it's an
interesting question
you know the plates are usually not
plastic anymore so at any place that's
worried about plastic straws it's
probably paper plates but that's just
Trump being out of touch he's probably
still in the mindset of the styrofoam
food containers or something who knows
so there are like three interesting
layers here because this is just some
dumb Trump statement but there's
actually important stuff here Trump
under the belief that the straws are
plastic but so are the plates and the
cups and everything is sort of saying
like to really deal with the plastic
problem you might have to consider
banning the plates and the utensils and
the cups and everything else because the
straws are really small he seems almost
like open to the idea of banning all
plastic implements of this kind like
he's sort of saying banning only plastic
straws doesn't go far enough
that's interesting because it doesn't
sound like it would be Donald Trump's
politics now the back story about the
straws specifically is that the reason
straws have gotten so much attention is
that every day 500 million of these
plastic straws are used once
and they're thrown away because they're
small people often don't even put them
in trash cans so that they contribute a
lot to Street trash they get into
waterways it's terrible for animals and
they're not recyclable anyway in most
cases because of their small size and
they contain such little plastic so they
wreak havoc so that part makes sense
that's why straws have become a thing
there's been a movement to replace Pat
plastic straws either by having people
carry around their own reusable metal
straw to only give customers straws when
they've asked for them instead of
bringing them to everybody there are
some alternative straws made of like
paper and bamboo and different things
every one I've tried is truly terrible
some coffee shops I go to have switched
to these for ice drinks and they just
fall apart into mush within 10 minutes
so it's true that while the straws
aren't a lot of plastic the things Trump
is mentioning often are paper and the
large plastic items are recyclable so he
just doesn't get why people are even
talking about straws okay the really
important message here is no matter what
we as individuals do in terms of
consumer choices like these if we don't
have big picture wholesale change to
pollution resource usage and energy
usage this stuff is a drop in the bucket
and that's why all of these consumer
movements are fine to the extent that
they'll inform people hopefully they
will impact human behavior in some way
that makes a small change but Trump is
sort of getting at the idea that listen
we're not going to solve the climate
crisis climate crisis that is with
straws we need to be thinking way bigger
the problem is Trump's against most of
those way bigger picture changes that
need to be made he's trying to
revitalize an industry that should be
allowed to die both because it's failing
and it's terrible for the environment
the coal mining industry just as one
example from producing benefits or
trying to reduce financial benefits on
electric cars he is completely right
that if we have this myopic focus on
straws we're missing the big a bigger
picture he just doesn't understand how
we're missing the big a bigger picture
and he's against most of the bigger
picture changes that would need to be
made if we even want to look just at
like landfills right
if you just look at solid waste
landfills it's obviously mostly not
straws or even items for eating food
it's electronics products it's wood and
large industrial plastics if we zoom out
and look at the bigger picture of solid
waste beyond just consumer we're talking
about industry and manufacturing and
construction that are generating just
untold amounts of waste way bigger than
straws we zoom out a little more and you
realize if we really want to fix this
issue we've got to look at energy usage
and then figure out where is energy
usage coming from and this dwarfs the
straw issue so my point is not laugh at
the plastic straw people or laugh at
Trump for what he said the plastic straw
people have a specific cause it's a
logical one Trump seems to be
identifying that the straw issue is not
the be-all end-all the bring your groan
on grocery bag movement it's a good
movement but what we have to realize is
that we have to be thinking way way
bigger than these retail level consumer
choices which are important but if we
want to make real change happen and this
is why lots of corporations end up
getting behind these movements we need
to look at industry and we need to look
at transportation big picture and we
need to look at energy this is why a lot
of big corporations will say oh yeah
we're fully behind the plastic straw
thing going to paper or only bringing
straws when people ask for them they are
appearing to be part of the solution
while the real problem which is the much
broader use of energy transportation
fossil fuels that these huge
corporations contribute to that gets
ignored every time the attention gets
put on straw so Trump is right straws
are not the solution but he's against
most of the solutions that really would
make a big impact